hey this is pretty funny not only does
British Prime Minister Boris Johnson
look like Donald Trump he's also
triggered just as easily by people who
disagree with him were very quickly
learning we've been covering the
atrocious idea that is brexit since the
vote back in June June 23rd of 2016 I
believe it was and whether brexit will
or won't ultimately happen we still
don't know although it's not looking
particularly good but in any case one of
the most recent sort of milestones or
events in the brexit saga was the
abandonment of the prime ministership by
Teresa May and her replacement by the
pro brexit conservative Boris Johnson
who looks a lot like Trump and we're
learning his trumpian in some other ways
and things have not been going
particularly well for Boris Johnson
between abandonment of the Tory Party by
one MP combined with a number of others
just not agreeing with Boris Johnson's
path forward on brexit he is managing a
brexit that is once again very much
imperiled and increasingly unpopular
yesterday Boris Johnson was in
Luxembourg and he was scheduled to do a
press conference with the prime minister
of Luxembourg and this is amazing they
come out of this meeting and there are
two lecterns and two microphones set up
for them and there's a lot of protests
that have got protesters rather that
have gathered in Luxembourg and the
prime minister of Luxembourg ends up
just walking Boris Johnson straight out
Boris Johnson just completely bails on
this press conference they had scheduled
and then around comes the Luxembourg
prime minister and actually does a
little bit of a press conference by
himself check this out we're gonna have
video here of Johnson walking out with
the Luxembourg prime minister and just
walking right on by the lectern and
straight out as a result of the
protesters and then the prime minister
of Luxembourg comes back around it
actually talks to the press show this is
live pictures as Boris Johnson leaves
the
unless the resin says just his name
well you can hear the noise that awaited
his departure and that has led to the
cancellation of the news conference that
was scheduled for 250 this happening as
the cameras on you see to the left have
a podium where they'd - promises would
have held that news conference but
because of the noise and booing and the
use for megaphone chants from many
British expats among them were told with
banners testing boys Breton capture
things through your mail over here from
the locks book on Easter right now so
let's just let's just listening
[Music]
thank you very much for listening to me
I think demonstrating is a right in a
democracy and it is important also to be
able to exchange and to listen to each
other this is just amazing first of all
how funny is it that Xavier Patel the
Luxembourg Prime Minister walks out with
Boris Johnson like clearly Boris Johnson
is fine
they had their meeting they walk right
by where the press conference was
supposed to taking place walks him right
out and then goes over to the lectern
and immediately people quiet right down
and he's able to talk with no problem
whatsoever and the hilarious explanation
from Boris Johnson's team was that it
was just too loud and rambunctious
because of those protesters rambunctious
being my word not theirs admittedly
and that it would just be really hard
for anybody to hear him if he
participated in in this press conference
and yet it seems like it was fine and he
would obviously have been given the
opportunity to speak what a brave guy
right at Trump wouldn't go to Britain
unless Britain could guarantee that
protests would be quashed and Trump
wouldn't have to be driving around met
by protesters and then you've got
British Trumpy and British Prime
Minister Boris Johnson going to
Luxembourg and just straight up walking
away from the press conference without
participating and there's a very
interesting parallel sort of developing
between Trump and Johnson other than as
I've said they have a very similar look
physically they're both triggered by
protesters very easily
they both are increasingly not respected
by other world leaders almost every
world leader other than I guess you know
some of the authoritarian types I guess
like Trump or I don't know if respect
Trump is the right word but most world
leaders don't respect the President of
the United the current President of the
United States fellow European Union
leaders increasingly don't respect Boris
Johnson and his harebrained ideas so
what hopefully this represents we may be
starting to see the pendulum sort of
swing back against the nationalist
authoritarian ideas that have been sort
of successfully masquerading as populism
over the last four to five years it's
become trendy in some circles hopefully
we're starting to see the pendulum
back the other way one other similarity
I'm seeing between Trump and Boris
Johnson is that the United Kingdom is
increasingly seen as a laughingstock
internationally as a result of the
endless brexit fiasco
much like the United States under Donald
Trump is also seen as a complete and
total laughingstock it's actually quite
remarkable the similarities that have
developed between the United States and
the UK over the last couple of years
we'll continue to follow brexit will
continue to follow Boris Johnson and the
ways in which he is increasingly similar
to the President of the United States
let me know what you think about him
just bailing walking right by the
lectern and going on out and back to
Britain I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
and make sure that you are following me
on twitch at twitch.tv slash David
Pakman if you have an Amazon Prime
membership already at no extra cost you
can subscribe to our twitch channel with
something called twitch Prime Amazon
Prime confers one free twitch Prime
membership per month costs you nothing
but it counts as a paid membership for
us it's like free money that you can
give us at twitch.tv slash David Pakman
today's program brought to you in part
by Blink accom slash Pakman blinka
is a great service that i use all the
time what they do is they take thousands
of the most popular non-fiction books
including the newest bestsellers they
condense them into 15-minute audiobooks
that you can listen to and you still get
the most crucial information and
insights from each book and I've
listened to a ton of books on blink Asst
I recently checked out soccer na mcc's
by Simon Cooper we do have after all the
World Cup going on recently we also have
been talking about BS jobs and there is
a great new book BS Jobs by David
Graeber which I listened to on blinka
they're constantly adding new books to
the platform you will never run out of
fascinating and critically acclaimed
books to enjoy and our audience can get
a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
/ Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I'm putting a link in the video
description and after the free trial if
you like it you can continue enjoying
thousands of condensed audiobooks for
about 5 bucks a month that's be Li NK is
t.com /p a que mas